qu'un
fais-le
[musique]
À combien de problèmes supplémentaires Chanak Ichcha Pramila est-il confronté ?
L'eau est tellement sale que de la mousse sort.
S'il y a trop de produits chimiques, alors
Beaucoup de problèmes et ils font notre Chhath
[Appréciation]
fais-le
Est arrivé
[musique]
Le puits est envahi par la végétation et l'eau est sale mais
C'est notre fête donc nous devons faire la fête.
Le gouvernement indien a raison dans cette réflexion, mais
Le gouvernement de Delhi a refusé et je
Ces gens sont venus de ce côté-ci, ils sont de ce côté-là.
fais-le chaque année
[musique]
allumer
qu'un
[musique]
Que
Les agriculteurs ont réalisé que ce gouvernement est un être humain.
si une décision a été prise ou non
Alors laissez-nous vous dire beaucoup de choses que vous
Que s'est-il passé, ils font de la politique, que font-ils ?
Existe-t-il un nettoyage en profondeur ? Cela n’existera pas.
Et c'est à eux de décider, pas à nos photos.
Nous allons donc nettoyer notre maison.
[musique]
fais-le